the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
ok so I've got a few things in mind for
today one is to answer those two
questions on the second line we answered
the two we found those two formulas on
the first line
last time the derivative of a inverse so
the derivative of a squared ought to be
easy but if we can't do that we need to
be sure we can and then this was the
derivative of an eigenvalue and then
it's natural asked about the derivative
of the singular value and i had a happy
day yesterday in the snow realizing that
that has a nice formula too of course
I'm not the first I'm sure that
Wikipedia already knows this formula but
it was new to me and I should say
professor Adelman has carried it to the
second derivative again not new but it's
it's more difficult to find second
derivatives and interesting but would
you stay with first derivatives okay so
it's my first item of sort of business
from last time and then I'd like to say
something about lab homeworks and ask
your advice and begin to say something
about a project and then I will move to
these topics in section 44 that you have
already and you might notice I skipped
fourth 0.3 and the reason is that on
Friday actually arriving at MIT tomorrow
is Professor Townsend
whose special 4.3 is all about his work
and he's the best lecturer I know he he
did the 8 you know so he was here as a
instructor and did 1806 and was a big
success
actually he's also just won prize for
the ZOA international prize for the for
the for young investigators young
faculty in applied linear algebra so
he's he goes to Hong Kong to get that
price to anyway he will be on the videos
and in here in the class Friday if all
goes well okay so in order then those in
order the first thing is the derivative
of a squared and you might think it's to
aid da/dt but it's not and if you
realize that it's not and you realize
what it is you will get these things
right in the future so the answer to the
derivative of a squared is not not to ad
a DT and why isn't it and what is the
right answer
so I do that maybe just below here
did anybody well I could ask you to
guess the right answer but why don't we
do it systematically so how do you find
the derivative it's a limit first you
have a delta a right and then you take a
limit so I look at a plus Delta a
squared minus a squared so that's the
change in a squared and I divide it by
delta T and then delta T goes to 0 so
that's the derivative I'm looking for
the derivative of a squared and now if I
write that out you'll see why this is
wrong but something very close to it of
course can't be far away is right so
what happens if I write this out the a
squared will cancel the a squared I'll
have what will I have will I have - a
delta a why don't I write - a delta a
next because a because when you're
squaring a sum of two matrices one term
is a delta a and another term is Delta a
a and those are different in general and
then Plus Delta V Delta a squared and
now I divide it all by delta T so you're
now seen my point that now I let Delta T
go to 0 so I'm just doing matrix
calculus and it's you know it's not
altogether simple but if you follow the
rules it comes out right so now what
what answer do I get as delta T goes to
0 I get a DA DT that's the definition of
the
that ratio goes to da/dt that's the
whole idea of the derivative of a and
now what's the other term it's da ETA so
it was simply that point that I wanted
you to pick up on that da the derivative
might not commute with a matrices don't
commute in general and so you notice
that we had a similar expression there
we had to pay attention to the order of
things there and now we get it right
it's not this but a da DT plus da DT a
okay good
now can I do the other one niche which
is a little more serious but it's it's a
beautiful formula and it's parallel to
this guy
you might even guess it so I'm looking
for the derivative of a singular value
the matrix a is changing da DT tells me
how it's changing at the moment at the
instant and I want to know how is Sigma
changing at that same instant and in
sort of in parallel with this is a nice
D nice formula you transpose da DT V of
T boy you couldn't ask for a nicer
formula and than that right so it's just
like this you remember this is the
eigenvector and that's the eigenvector
of a transpose so this is the singular
vector of a and you could say this is
the singular vector of a transpose or
it's the left singular vector of a so
that would be our that's our
formula and if we can just recall how to
prove it which is going to be parallel
to the proof of that one then I'm a
happy person and we can get on with life
okay so so just let's let's let's
remember this because it'll help us to
remember the other one too okay so where
do I start I start with a formula for a
sigma so I believe that Sigma is U
transpose times a times e everybody
agree with that everything is depending
on T in this in this formula as time
changes everything changes but I didn't
write in the parentheses T three three
more times okay can we just remember
about the SVD the SVD says that a times
V equals save my you thanks a B is Sigma
u that's the SVD so when I put in for a
V I put in Sigma u Sigma is just a
number so I bring it outside and I'm
left with u transpose U and what's u
transpose u what so I've used these two
facts or I could have gone the other way
and said that this is the transpose of
this is a transpose u transpose I
couldn't look at it that way
times V and if I look at it that way I'm
interested in what is a transpose U and
what is a transpose u its Sigma V and
its transpose so Sigma V transpose V and
what is Sigma V transpose V its Sigma
again of course got Sigma both ways okay
no now I'm ready to take
here's that's the formula I have for
four Sigma completely parallel to the
formula that we started out with for
lambda the eigenvalue was y transpose ax
and now we've got u transpose AV and by
the way when would those be
those two formulas be one and the same
when would we when does the SVD just
tell us nothing new beyond the
eigenvalue stuff for what matrices are
the singular values the same as the
eigenvalues and seeing other vectors the
same as this as the eigenvectors for for
symmetric good symmetric square and the
two words that i'm them always looking
for in this course you could if you want
an A in this course just write down
positive definite when and the answer to
any question because Sigma's are by
definition positive and if they're going
to agree totally with the lambdas then
the lambdas have to be positive or could
be 0 so positive semi definite would be
the right answer anyway this is our
start okay and what do we do with that
formula so so we this was all the same
because V transpose V was one here I had
V transpose V and that's one so it gave
me Sigma yeah good
everybody's with it okay what do I do
takes the derivative takes the
derivative of that equation in the Box
exactly what I did last time with the
corresponding equation for lambda same
thing and I'm going to get again it's a
product rule because I have three things
multiplied on the right hand side so
I've got three terms from the product
rule so D Sigma D T coming from the box
is du u transpose D t AV was you
transpose da DT V plus the third guy
which will be new transpose a DVD did I
get the three terms there yep
I'm which term do I want which term do I
believe is going to survive and be the
answer well this is what I'm after so
it's the middle term the middle term is
just right and the other two terms had
better be zero so that that will be the
proof the to the other two terms will be
zero so can we just take one of those
two terms and show that it's zero like
this one okay what have I got here I
want to know that that term is zero so
what have I got I've got do you
transpose D T times AV and everybody
says okay in place of AV right in Sigma
U and Sigma is a number so I don't mind
putting it there okay so I've got Sigma
a number times the derivative of U times
u itself the dot product the derivative
of U with dot product with u and that
equals zero I hope because of this
because of that I'm taking this comes
from the derivative of that the
derivative will be but but you see now
we've got dot products ordinary dot
products and and a number on the right
hand side we're in dimension one you
could say so this this tells me
immediately that the derivative of U
with u plus u transpose times the
derivative of U
is the derivative of 1 which is 0 yeah
oh all I'm saying is those these are the
same you know vectors X transpose Y is
the same as Y transpose X when I'm
talking about real numbers if I was
doing complex things which I could do
then I'd have to pay attention and take
if and and take complex conjugates at
the right moment but no it's not bother
so you see this is just two of these and
it gives me 0 so that terms golf and
similarly totally similarly this term is
gone this is a transpose U but what this
is a transpose u all transpose I'm just
doing the same thing times dv/dt and
what is a transpose u it's Sigma V so
this is Sigma V transpose DV DT and
again 0 because of this so in a way this
was a slightly easier thing that the
last time was a completely parallel
computation but the first and third
terms had to cancel each other with the
X's and Y's
now they disappear separately leaving
the right answer ok that's you might
think how did we get into derivatives of
singular values well I think if we're
going to understand the SVD then the
first derivative of the of Sigma is a
well except that I've survived all these
years without knowing it so you could
say it's not
you know you can you can live without it
but it's a pretty nice formula okay that
completes that sections 3-1 and and more
to say about 3/2 which was the
interlacing part that I introduced okay
so where am I
I guess I'm thinking about the neat
topics in about interlacing of
eigenvalues so may I pick up on that
seem interlacing of eigenvalues and say
what's in the notes general idea okay so
we're leaving the leaving derivatives
and moving to finite changes in the
eigenvalues and singular values and we
are recognizing that we can't get exact
formulas for the change but we can get
bounds for the change and they are
pretty cool so let me remind you what
that is what they are so so I have a
matrix that's C a symmetric matrix S
that has eigenvalues lambda 1 greater
equal lambda 2 greater equal so on then
I change s by some amount I think in the
notes there's a number say there times a
rank one matrix that has eigenvalues
view 1 greater equal mewtwo greater
equal something and these are what I
can't give you an exact formula for you
just would have to compute them but I
can give you bounds for them and the
bounds come from the lambdas so the
bounds are so this was a positive
this is a positive change so the
eigenvalues will go up or stay still but
they won't go down
so the muse will be bigger than the
lambdas but the neat thing is that they
don't you two will not pass up lambda 1
so I'll have mute here's the interlacing
nu 1 is greater or equal lambda 1 that
says that the highest eigenvalue the top
eigenvalue went up or didn't move but
but mu 2 is below lambda 1 the new this
is the new everybody's with me here this
is the new and this is the old new and
old being oldest s nu is with the change
in s and that mu 2 is greater equal
lambda 2 so the second eigen values went
up and then so on that's the that's the
great fact and I guess that I sent out a
puzzle question did did it arrive in
email about suppose so
does anybody see that puzzle question
and think about it
so here's it worried me for a while
suppose this change as it is suppose I'm
adding on here suppose this is the
second eigenvalue eigenvector so i'm
adding on i'm hyping up the second
eigenvector hyping up the matrix in the
direction of the second eigenvector so
i'm really so the second eigenvalue was
lambda 2 and it's beauty the new second
eigenvalue is going to be bigger by
theta but this then i lost a little
sleep in thinking okay if the second
eigenvalue is mu 2
Plus theta I'm sorry if the second
eigenvalue mewtwo so so let me write it
here
if mu2 the second eigenvalue is the old
lambda 2 plus theta then then then then
bad news because theta can be as big as
I want it can be 2200 mm and when I if
this mu 2 if I'm just adding theta 2 to
lambda 2 to get that second because it's
the second eigenvector that that's
getting pumped up then after a while
mu tou will pass lambda 1 this will be
totally true I have no worries about
this the old lambda 1 actually the old
the old I'll even have equality here
because for this particular change it's
not affecting lambda 1 so I think mu 1
would be lambda 1 in in my hypothetical
possibility where I'm trying to get you
to do is to think through what this
means because it's quite easy to write
that line there but then when you think
about it you get some questions and it
looks 10 it looks as if it might fail
right because if theta is really big
that Mew 2 would pass up lambda 1 and
the thing would fail and there has to be
a catch it has to be a catch so does
anybody Minh you saw that in the email
and I'll now explain what I how I
understood that the ever that everything
can work and there isn't where I'm not
reaching a contradiction and here's my
thinking
so it's perfectly true that the
eigenvalue that goes with you - or maybe
I should be calling them X - because
usually I call the eigenvectors x2 it's
perfectly true that mu - that that one
goes up but what happens when it hits
when it reaches lambda 1 actually lambda
1 the first eigenvalue is staying put
because it's not getting any push from
this but the second eigenvalue is
getting a push of size theta so so what
happens when mute when lambda 2 plus
theta which is mu 2 u 2 is lambda 2 plus
theta what happens when it comes up to
lambda 1 and I start worrying that it
passes lambda 1 you see what's happening
there what happens when mu 2 passes when
mu 2 which is I'm just going to copy
here it's the old lambda 2 plus the same
as a number what happens when theta gets
bigger and bigger and bigger and this
hits this thing and then goes beyond
just to see the logic here what happens
is that this lambda 2 plus theta which
was mu 2 mu 2 until they've got here but
what is lambda 2 plus theta after it
passes lambda 1 its lambda 1 now it
passed up so it's the top eigenvalue of
the of the of the altered matrix and
therefore it's just fine it's out here
no problem yeah
maybe I'll just say it again when when
theta is big enough that mu 2 reaches
lambda 1 if I increase theta beyond that
then this becomes not mu 2 anymore but u
1 and then totally everybody's happy
okay I'll just I won't say more on that
because that's just like a way for that
I found to make me sink what do these
things mean okay enough said on that
small point but then the main point is
why is this true
it's interlacing which is really a nice
beautiful fact and you could imagine
that we have more different
perturbations than just rank ones so
suppose yeah so so let me tell you the
the inequality so named after they
discover vials inequality so his
inequality is for the eigenvalues of s
plus T and I want to yeah so T is the
change s is where I start it has
eigenvalues lambda but now I'm looking
at the eigenvalues of s plus T so so I'm
making a change in over here and my
little puzzle question that was teens it
was a rank one change now I could allow
other ranks okay so I want to estimate
lambdas of s plus T in terms of lambdas
of s and lambdas of T and I want some
inequality sign there and it's supposed
to be true for any symmetric matrices
symmetric smt and then a totally totally
identical violin equality actually viol
was one of the people who discovered
seen Euler values and when he did it he
asked about his inequality and he found
that it still worked the way we found
this morning earlier that it said what
I'm what I haven't I haven't completed
that yet because I haven't told you
which lambdas I'm talking about
right so let me do that so now tell your
files inequality so S&T or symmetric and
so the lambdas are real and we want to
know we want to get them in order okay
so here it goes
I'm going to over here I'm gonna file
aloud the ice eigenvalue of s and the
json value of t and figured out that
this was founded by that eigenvalue of S
Plus T so that's vilest great inequality
which reduces to the the the one I wrote
here if I make the right choice yeah
probably if I take J equal to one so so
this was you see the beauty of this it
tells you about all any eigen values of
s eigen values of T so I'm using lambdas
here lambda of s are the eigenvalues of
s I'm using lambda again for T and
lambda again for s plus T so it's that
you have to pay attention to which
matrix I'm taking the eigen values of so
let me take J equal to one then this
says that lambda I because J is 1 s plus
T plus R equal lambda I of s plus lambda
1 the top eigen value of T this is
lambda max of T
do you see that that's totally
reasonable believable that the
eigenvalues when I add on T let's
imagine in our minds that T is positive
T is T is like this this thing this is
the this could be the T example of a tea
it's what I'm adding on then the
eigenvalues go up but they don't pass
that so that tells you how much it could
go up by so I guess that I guess that
vial is telling us is giving us a less
or equal here less or equal to lambda1
so I'm taking I to be 1 plus theta yeah
yeah
so that inequality I've written down
there there's some playing around to do
so to get practice and it's not so
essential for us to be like world
grandmasters at this thing but you
should see it and you should also see J
equal to 2y will J equal to 2 tell us
something I hope it will let's see what
it tells us lambda I plus 1 now J is 2
of S Plus T so it's a is less than or
equal lambda I of s plus lambda 2 of T I
think that's interesting or and and also
I could take I think I also could get
lambda I plus I minus 1 so these let me
write it and see if it's correct plus
lambda I minus 1 so that was added up to
I plus 2 yeah I guess lambda I plus 1
plus lambda one of teeth
yeah that's what I got by taking yeah do
that right I'm taking J equal to one
oh well did I I don't think I got it
right what am what do I want to do here
to get a bound on lambda I plus one I
want to take J equal to 2 I should just
be sensible and plug in a equals 2 and I
equal 1 all I want to say is that viols
inequality is the great fact out of
which all this interlacing Falls and
more and more because the interlacing is
telling me about neighbors and actually
if I use vile for a and I and J
different eyes and J's I even learn
about ones that are not neighbors but
and I could tell you a proof of Vile's
inequality but I'll save that for the
notes yes okay so I think maybe that's
what I want to do about interlacing just
just to say what the notes have but not
repeat it all in class so the notes have
actually two ways to prove this
interlacing the standard way that every
mathematician would use would be Vile's
inequality but less dear professor Rao
visiting found a nice argument that's
also in the notes it ends up with a
graph and on that graph you can see that
this is true so for what it's worth two
approaches to this to this interlacing
and some examples but I really don't
want to spend
our lives on that chopper this
eigenvalue topic it's it's a beautiful
fact about symmetric matrices and the
the corresponding fact is true for
singular values of any matrix but let's
I think of leaving it there okay so now
I'm moving on to their new section the
new section involves something called
compressed sensing I don't know if
you've heard those words so these are
all topics in Section 4.4 which you have
from I think we send it out ten days ago
probably okay so first let me remember
what the nuclear norm is of a matrix the
nuclear norm of a matrix is the sum of
the singular values there's some of the
singular values so it's like the l1 norm
for a vector that's a right way to think
about it and do you remember what was
special we we've talked about the using
the l1 norm it has this special special
property that the ordinary l2 norm
absolutely does not have what was it
special about the hell one norm if I
minimize some minimize the l1 norm with
E with some constraint like ax a V equal
B what's special about the solution the
minimum in the l1 norm sparse right
sparse so this is moving us up two
matrices and that's where compressed
sensing comes in matrix come
Leeson comes in so here matrix
completion would just be I mentioned so
this is completion and I'll remember the
words Netflix which made the problem
famous so I have the matrix a 3-2
question mark question mark question
mark one four six question one missing
data and so I have to put in something
there because if I don't put in anything
then the numbers I have dunno are
useless as I can't know row and no
column is complete so we just would give
up somebody that sent me the data three
and two and didn't sell tell me a
ranking for the third movie I'd have to
say well I can't use it
that's not possible so we need to think
about there and the idea is that the
numbers that minimize the nuclear norm
are a good choice a good choice so
that's just a connection here that we'll
say more about but not not we could have
a whole course compressed sensing a
nuclear norm
professor Perillo and and of course in
six of course six is an expert on this
but the point is you see the point that
so what is the you remember V V one came
from the zero north
and what is the zero norm of a vector
well it's not a norm so you could say
forget it no no answer but what do we
symbolically mean when I write the zero
norm of a vector I mean the number of
non-zeros the number of non-zeros
this was the number of non zero in the
main event but it's not a norm because
if I take two times the vector I have
the same number of non-zeros same norm I
can't have the norm of two V equal to
norm of e that that that would blow away
all the properties of norms so V zero is
not a norm and we move it to the sort of
appropriate nearest norm and we get V 1
we get the L 1 norm which is the sum of
the everybody remembers that this is the
sum of the V on and you remember my
pictures of diamonds touching planes at
sharp point well that's what's going on
here that problem was called basis
pursuit and comes back again in this
section ok but so I minimize this norm
subject to the conditions okay now I'm
just going to take a jump to the matrix
case what's my idea here my idea is that
the for matrix the nuclear norm comes
from what what's the norm that we sort
of start with but it's not a norm and
when I sort of take the I sort of
because of triangle inequality or the
requirements for a norm don't fail they
fail for what
I'm about to write there I could put a
zero but I don't want the number of
nonzero entries that would be a good
guess and probably in some sense it make
it make sense but it's not the answer
I'm looking for
what do you think is the zero norm of a
matrix that that is not a norm but when
I pump it up to the best to the nearest
good norm I get the nuclear in order so
so this is the question is what is a
zero what the rank the rank of the
matrix is is the equivalent is the is
the is the so I don't know about the
zero nobody else calls at a zero so I
better not it's the rank so again the
rank is not a norm because if I double
the matrix I don't double the rank but
if so I have to move to a norm and it
turns out to be the nuclear norm and now
I'll just one minute say it's the guess
of some people who are working hard to
prove it that the deep learning
algorithm of gradient descent finds the
solution to the minimum problem in the
nuclear norm and I don't we don't know
if that's true or not
yeah we're first small for for related
examples like this thing it's proved for
the exact problem of deep learning it's
it's a conjecture okay
so that's what's in Section four four
but other that word lasso you want to
know what that is compressed sensing
I'll say a word about so that will be
Monday after Alex Townsend's lecture
Friday so he's he's coming to speak
- computational science students all
over MIT tomorrow afternoon I'll
certainly go to that but then he said he
would come in and take this class Friday
so I'll see you Friday
and he'll be here - okay